SETH VARGOS: Welcome back.
Next up we have Ahmet.
Ahmet, why don't you tell us
a little bit of what you do?
AHMET ALP BALKAN: Sure, Seth.
My name is Ahmet.
I'm a developer programs
engineer at Google Cloud.
I work on Google
Kubernetes engine,
[INAUDIBLE] project and so on.
SETH VARGOS: Awesome.
So you've been working in
Kubernetes for quite a while.
I've been following your career.
What's one of the
biggest pain points
that you see in the Kubernetes
ecosystem right now?
AHMET ALP BALKAN: Yeah.
So my primary audiences
are developers,
and I think developers deal
with these command line
tools want not a lot.
So I'm seeing that in some
inner iteration circles,
there's a lot of developer
cycles wasted, if you will.
That is like going towards
just these simple things
around tools like Kube control.
So I like to develop tools and
shortcuts around Kube control.
That's my personal passion.
SETH VARGOS: And Kube
control is like one
of the main ways in which
people submit everything
to Kubernetes, right?
AHMET ALP BALKAN: Yeah.
SETH VARGOS: So what are some
of the problems around Kube
control?
Or where can we expand it?
Or where are people
hitting pain points?
AHMET ALP BALKAN: So there's
like an entire open source
special interest group, Sig
CLI, in Kubernetes that's
dealing with that problem.
One of the areas that they
propose improvement is that
they cannot possibly implement
everything that people want.
So they wanted to provide
some extension capability
around kubectl.
So they basically
said, hey, why don't we
provide in plugin
systems so that people
can write their own
programs around kubectl,
and they can invoke them through
the kubectl command line.
SETH VARGOS: Have you
written any plugins yourself?
AHMET ALP BALKAN:
Yeah, I've been playing
with some plugins myself.
One thing that actually
I've been working on
is a plugin manager called Krew.
So this is basically
[INAUDIBLE] Mac OS and this--
it's Kubernetes K, so {} There
is a nautical theme there,
if you can catch that.
SETH VARGOS: So
K-R-E-W, not C-R-E-W.
AHMET ALP BALKAN: Yes.
Yes, that's right.
So this is a project that
we've been working on
at Google Cloud.
This actually-- this project
was started by my intern
this summer, Luke Pritchard.
He's [INAUDIBLE] on GitHub.
So he's a super cool
guy, and w started
this project called Krew.
So what Krew does is it's a
plugin manager for a kubectl.
So if you want to
discover plugins,
if you want to install
plugins, you can go to Krew,
install Krew onto your
computer, and then from there
you can discover new plugins and
just bring them to your machine
and then use it with kubectl.
SETH VARGOS: So I
assume it's open source.
AHMET ALP BALKAN: Yes.
This is open source.
If we haven't
announced it a lot,
I guess this is probably the
biggest announcement so far.
SETH VARGOS: You heard
it here first, people.
AHMET ALP BALKAN: Yeah.
And then right now we're in the
process of talking to Sig CLI
to perhaps donate this project
to Kubernetes open source
community and make it
a non-Google project.
SETH VARGOS: Well, so let's
get technical for a bit.
Since this is the announcement,
how does Krew find plugins?
Is there a registry, GitHub?
How do we find them?
AHMET ALP BALKAN: So we
have a central registry
on GitHub W Outbreak currently.
Anyone who would do
all those plugins,
we just need those people
to package their plugins
into, say, something like
a tarball or zip file,
and then they write a
manifest file describing how
the plugin should be installed.
And then they submit
this plugin manifest
file to the central
repository that we have,
and then from there everyone
can discover those plugins.
So if you're shopping
for some, let's say,
a plug to read the
logs, you don't
have to go to Google
Search and like search what
are the plugins that I can use.
So you can just come to
Krew and search for logs,
and then we'll show
you all the plugins
that are about log reading.
SETH VARGOS: Well,
so let's go back.
Let's say Krew doesn't exist.
How do I get a plugin into
kubectl today without Krew?
AHMET ALP BALKAN: Yeah.
Well, first of all,
you need to find
that a plugin that you're
looking for exists.
I think that's one of
the biggest problems,
and that's one of
the primary reasons
that we just started Krew.
Discoverability is one of the
largest problems out there.
So after you find
the plugin, you
need to download
to your package,
and then you need to name
it in a specific phase.
So let's say you have
a plugin called food,
so you need to name
it kubectl-food
and then put it into
somewhere in your path.
And if you put it in your
path and everything is good,
you can invoke it by
saying kubectl space food.
So that's how you install
and set up plugins.
SETH VARGOS: That sounds
like a lot of magic.
AHMET ALP BALKAN:
So imagine you're
installing 10 to
15 plugins, and you
have to keep them up to date
because all these plugins will
have newer versions.
So that's another thing that
Krew solves really well.
If you manage the
plugin lifecycle
and we can bring the
updates automatically,
you basically say, hey,
kubectl Krew update,
and we basically update
all these plugins
if they have newer versions.
SETH VARGOS: Awesome.
So this thing
sounds really cool.
One, where can people get more
information, and two, what's
the future look like for Krew?
AHMET ALP BALKAN: Yeah.
So people can go
to GitHub.com/Googl
eContainerTools/Krew with
K. Feel free to try it out.
I think we're on something
like version 0.2.
This is still very early days.
So far it's been working fine.
We have over, I think,
almost 20 plugins.
By the way, there are
not a lot of plugins yet,
so we also want people to
think about plugin ideas
and what to develop.
But also we want to donate
Krew to Kubernetes project,
so we want it to be a Kubernetes
Sig CLI project that perhaps
someday eventually
rolls into kubectl,
so that you can just say
kubectl plugins install food.
So we want to go to a world
where these sort of things
are easily discoverable
and manageable.
SETH VARGOS: Awesome.
Thank you very much, Ahmet.
AHMET ALP BALKAN:
Thank you, Seth.